[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we talk about whatever we want
i didn't even separate the action from
hey guys i wonder if the editor
sometimes they add the three to one
action you know that you know i didn't
even know that that was a thing until
like you guys brought it up one time and
i was like really they're using that in
the beginning
action sometimes they leave the
conversations that we have before
action those get dangerous because i'm
assuming that they're not gonna use the
things until after the action you know
what's dangerous paper cut on the nipple
i dare you five bucks no but they didn't
do that tiff because our editors
got our back say 500 the minute you step
out of your house
you have to be ready for people to start
quoting you yep that's what i'm very
scared it's hard being bart
[ __ ] you i say the craziest [ __ ] i'm not
even trying to say crazy [ __ ] it'd be
really hard
what did they quote you like what do
people say i'm just
trying to have a good time and then and
then i get in trouble
dude me too i'm just trying to like say
my thoughts and accidentally i roast
people like crazy and i'm like i don't
even mean well those are good though
what happens to me you're a good roaster
i like it knowing it i like it i like it
so it's so offensive i love it
there's so many like uh like say like
muslims that watch this right i'll be
talking about like a muslim subject
and the second they hear me start
talking like you're wrong you're wrong
and then they started like it should be
like this and like
re-listen to what i said and they're
like oh
no we're saying the same thing i'm sorry
i didn't listen to the whole thing i'm
like then why are you in common
what if they're muslim fobs and they
don't speak english that well
it could be then it shouldn't be i mean
every time i talk about some history and
then they're like
joe you think you know what the [ __ ] you
talking about you so wrong and i
research it and i'm like yeah i am wrong
i feel like if you were a superhero that
would be like your costume
[ __ ] [ __ ] joe looks like bruce
lee on the lsd
like trying to go somewhere now you have
a little curl happening in now the other
end
right there right there joel looks crazy
as [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] crucified
yeah keep turning your head like
superhero style because your [ __ ]
hair flips up yeah
that looks like you're all oh tom's
crazy there it
because tom cruise is a japanese last
samurai dude
that's why i was like how does he play
into this
well he's also mr matrix which is one of
my favorite movies tom cruise
yeah that's counter no but in my brain
tom cruiser made a pretty cool neo
right yeah i don't think so you don't
think so keanu is so
weird to begin with just himself that i
feel like he was perfect to be neo yeah
he was just himself but imagine the
scene where neo
is trying to run away for the first time
realizing he's in the matrix right he's
at his like this guy right here
yeah that guy yeah he got it going in
between he's like running like this with
the [ __ ]
i think that looks good that guy you're
[ __ ] tom cruise playing the role
they've been pretty
i think tom cruise is too confident in
his physical he's really intense
so you're like oh this guy's an action
star yeah keanu is moving around you're
like
this is an office guy that didn't know
what to do if they did remake it i feel
like they should put the rock
just to be so crazy as morpheus no as
as keanu as music oh right he was i'm
the one just hella big
or the rocks like just the oracle the
lady
she was my favorite character the oracle
did she die or just not get rehired
because it changed persons
i don't know i don't know yeah the
oracle in the first or second
and was different from the from the last
one i thought she just beams him doing
different [ __ ] because she can't
yeah i don't even get like what her role
is is she an ai she's an ai she's an ai
that's why i thought she could just keep
coming back as other things
oh yeah i think that they used that to
let a different actress who was hired
come back
you guys heard that conspiracy where uh
they stole the stuff from a lady
that looks like the oracle and then what
ended up happening
was that lady sued
the movie like it was written by someone
else yeah and then she looks like
the the lady oracle oh she looks like
her
i don't know that yeah have you seen the
someone edited guns into harry potter
and source of stone
instead of wands they said it once it
looks so real
but they're like shooting each other and
it's like like bloods coming out of
people's heads when they shoot
that's crazy i gotta watch that that's
so [ __ ] funny oh that's crazy
what's one of your childhood favorites
that you'd want to see remake that they
haven't remade i feel like i don't want
to see
blood sport i want to see blood sport
with all the
current mma fighters and i don't want
them to make it
good like i don't want like it i still
want to have that like
shitty like 80s kind of feel where the
editing is kind of bad we're like the
scene started and the guy goes
and then he moves but i just want to see
like
like my favorite mma fighters in that
movie you know because for me
i would actually want to see something
that i hated as a child be rema
remade because i don't want them
touching the [ __ ] that i like what did
you ruin it what did you hate oh she's
like
cinderella i didn't like tripping though
i was i could never get into or not chip
and doll sorry
the chipmunks they like the way that
they talk i couldn't stand the way they
talk
it's just a sped up record remember that
was a huge thing on youtube where they
would just speed up the audio
and that was like everyone would go
viral like people found fred
it was such a simpler time back what's
he up to now
i don't know but he should stick around
super rich
probably yeah where's fred now i've seen
something about him like pretty
recently he's just doing normal [ __ ]
really what's normal like what dancing
fred's not even his real name right
isn't it like is it lucas or something
i mean people dance right sadly
i think it's weird when people don't
dance i think that's abnormal
i don't think it's abnormal because i
think dancing is such a
natural human thing like breathing like
every child
dances like if you play music you don't
even teach that [ __ ] they're
just like
now if you grew up in a middle eastern
family that made you embarrassed when
you did something
yeah but that's learned but you still
have to learn man but they would like
almost when you're a shy kid put you in
the spotlight so it made you shut down
even more
oh they wanted you to dance yeah like oh
that's like
yeah in the car at home no i try to and
then i feel like there's like there's
someone
i get embarrassed for myself oh but i
got these new teeth now
wait you're saying you get embarrassed
when you dance by yourself i'll try
singing and then i'll like start like
laughing oh me too
that happens to me all the time with
singing and with dancing i really don't
know why
i laugh at myself i can't take myself
singing by myself
i'm literally like babyface and it's
weird that when there's someone else
next to me all of a sudden i can't sing
as good as i did by myself
oh you get nervous yeah it even happens
like when i try being like sexy
seductive i just [ __ ] laugh because
i'm like this you do laugh
oh i can't ever like you too you laugh
too though because i'm like okay do a
striptease for me yeah you be like dude
do you like
magic mike and i'm like all right magic
might get up and then we just we can't
ask for it
it just has to happen won't come hey
i don't know if it's normal for a guy to
just naturally want to start magic mike
in it
right exactly so i have to ask i have to
the guy there's the guy that doesn't
dance at all
but it's different when it's actually
like the candles on no oh i it's
different when it's actual what
sexual oh sexual yeah that's how it
always is baby
it's always sexual deduction
seduction damn i want to see if i don't
know if i really
want to see it but if there was like a
camera in joe's room no
no never why why not
oh here's how you want to see joe having
sex no no why [ __ ]
just like the pre i'm actually
interested too wait
you've seen joe having sex get him in
the bed
no i'm a jackhammer kind of guy nope i
can't be later on
an interesting question i'm interested
in how joe has sex and how joe has four
play
oh i'm gonna know the poor play just i
don't know man
depends on the person is all i gotta say
some people
bring out the beast in me do you have
goat do you have go-to
moves nah just i have to read the person
in the vibes man
i feel like joe like pull out a condom
and make like a blue animal for them
no it's a clown all the way it changes
over time
because like i mean i'm trying to do
someone right now
is this your seduction feels good it's
working
like a japanese karen from the future
i know hold on let me i did my hair
today and trying to do that you could
use mine bro
there's like uh things going around like
twitter it's like this
is it the same way well everyone
everyone just comes up and wants to like
touch it
i want to touch your five o'clock shadow
bald head i don't
i don't it's just like it's it's kind of
smooth right now because i just did last
night does it feel like this
no okay thank you thank you i
for answering me attention
some people touch here but some people
touch their balls
and did you know that you could have way
more fun if you try out adam and eve
oh yeah and eve says the best part of
staying at home is
playing at home i like that if you have
a camera on me i'll be
using adam and eve all the time yeah so
take advantage of the downtime and
choose almost
any one item at 50 percent
off if your limit to your hands you
don't always have to use your hands you
can use all kinds of different toys and
have a way better time
i might start evolving myself in that
area
and when you do you'll get 10 free
boredom busting gifts including six
spicy movies boredom bus three
piece bonus kit and best of all free
shipping delivered discreetly right to
your door i need it to be discreet
because i don't want the postal man
looking at a big [ __ ] ass cheek
and they're gonna say dildo and i'm like
joe
or dildo huge ass cheeks so it's like
it's like
fake ass inside [ __ ] feels so good it's
almost like it's real that's on the
outside of the box
what if it says [ __ ] like that what if
it says stuff like that and he's just
kind of like damn that's good
like when you're getting a tv in the
mail and they bring it to you in the tv
box yeah right outside your garage door
yeah i wonder what that could be right
so if you want to spice up your sex life
go to adamandeve.com use offer code
otr to get one item at fifty percent oh
thank you adam and eve
of adam and eve sponsored by adam
have you ever ordered a dildo online
before yeah so
yeah not though though gotcha
i ordered a sex toy online what was it
uh it was like a dragon ball z character
oh wait how was that toy like it was
like oh i was like a blow up bulma
what a bulma they get those like anime
figurines in some
in the most craziest positions man
they're very creative and they are yeah
it's so nasty and all the japanese girls
that are drawn are like
so hot really just like unattainable
like standards are japanese people
drawing
japanese people there are girls that
look like that blonde and blue eyed and
like huge busts and stuff like that
there's girls with those bodies they're
called they're called av girls no
i'm just saying like that's what they
draw like raw anime and like
like for example like naruto right i
don't know if you've fallen off
but like he's blonde blue eyes so are
they like
drawing a white person or is it a white
person sometimes it's
um an alien or whatever or like it's
just their idea
but true and then sometimes they're
meant to be white or sometimes they're
just like japanese people with bleached
hair because that's the style
well dragon balls dragon balls it has
like like nazi
undertones honestly i'm saying when they
turn like super saiyan they like turn to
white
blue eyes and blonde hair whereas when
he has asian features he's like nash
that's powerful no they they they
answered that they said that he's
uh alien he's not japanese that's the
best way to answer that nah kakarot
can't
counter that because you know why people
are aliens so anytime somebody's like
racist it's like no no i'm not racist
i'm just
alien right but it's strange
because i know like yeah like some of
them are okay so like in
um street fighter right you know the ken
character
so ken's character you know how he looks
white because he has blonde hair
he has black eyebrows though yeah but
he's supposed to be a white guy
that was an army kid so he's like half
japanese or something oh
and then he was trained under the same
karate master as ryu
the wanderer yeah it was like the dog
because i just know right
saying christina's oh yeah yeah that's
funny you only know ryu
as a dog was kidding it was a joke
did that hurt this tattoo this one only
right here at the very very tip it's
always a small
how long did that take this one took
like 25 minutes 30 minutes that's so
fast how long did it last whole life to
earn it what is that
it's the kindred can just tattoo i could
do one right now just join your crew
significantly um fatter right because i
don't know
if that's what it takes to get in your
crew i'll do that [ __ ] and then be a
poser
i dare you yeah and then i'll just pose
everywhere and be like
i'm a kendra dude like the guy in 300
smarter the deformed one that keeps
following them around
tease or whatever and then he like lusts
over the goat head person yeah but guess
what it's because of
me that the persians came in and [ __ ]
them all up
so you you'd go against the kenji's and
get them ruined hell yeah
it'll immortalize us though right i'll
be like
i guess we never did
like a jk thing jk just like a party
like jiggy party initiation
pretty much like a jk tattoo or like
yeah you want a jk tattoo don't you did
you guys all get like rolexes
no no no i think there's these but
that's not a jk thing
that's just a greedy thing yeah so what
so what would be a jk thing
i think did they should get us rolex's i
think i'll be tight
that would be cool going through jk
party right like all that
hawaii too like we've all been to hawaii
and like not everyone
tripped no no we didn't take everyone
cruz what you're saying is we took
everyone to vegas hawaii with you guys
yeah what do you want you want you want
violence or you want something
else what do you want do you want what's
the something else
something else is like you could get
like a fish you want to get
something else means i haven't thought
of it you want trauma or tropical
tropical trauma i'll give you tropical
trauma how about the drama leeches in
your butthole
oh just kidding beat you with a coconut
i feel like he's been around i feel i
feel like i i called him the
the distant the the cousin i called him
the [ __ ] cousin now like people that
are kind of
jk family but not really a part of the
family
like david he's a cousin cousin
yeah with a kid nah david's more like
the adopted kid that we didn't really
want around but we had to bring him in
david
yeah like he was forced yeah he was
forced to come in
yeah so he you you didn't want him
around but he was forced to get in
that's the point where i was like
david yeah i forced myself to bring him
in because like
um i felt like he was too lonely
i didn't want him around but i did yeah
how do you remember that
i don't want him around but i did is
that what he did with
genius brain with you nah he needed me
and then
i i said you know what like i think it's
time for you to
grow on your own not just kidding corona
happened and then we just couldn't
schedule it and i was it's just kind of
lazy
yeah so that's kind of what happened
there um
i think that we have a it's kind of like
this unspoken
thing right where like the people that's
been around together the longest
as jk were kind of like close because we
don't have anything else but jk
and then we have kind of like people
that are doing their own thing but they
hang out so much with us that they
become associated with us
like stephen nicky or like gina or like
david or whatever right
now anthony yeah but then you guys have
your own things going on so it's like
extended family member i cut my own
thing then that's my chance
bro if you cut your thing i'm gonna make
you cut it so hard that
you forget it sick this is a this is a
this is a family man if he cuts this
thing it's worthless to us
that's true that's oh that's true the
thing is he's dancing or are you talking
about his penis
it's dancing got it i was ready to cut
my dick off for jk but really
nah dude you guys are messed up you know
why it feels like
it feels like we're a country and you're
kind of like
puerto rico one of the small ones you
know like one of the smaller countries
the u.s territory
that are like diplomatic with us so you
represent dc
or what not like we're okay so like
we're like america and you're like
canada or something you know sick yeah
so you're cool
but he's better yeah he's better he's
better in a way
[Laughter]
all right all right we're like we're
like we're like we're like china and
you're like kind of hong kong or am i
just more like
we're not fighting we're not fighting
never mind changing
changing like alaska are you trying to
rule him oh yeah maybe you're a no
you're not a state
you haven't earned it if you're a state
that means you're one of us you know
what i mean like you're not quite
america
yeah but that's a country that's like
puerto rico guam right like a territory
no because he's a kenja right
so he's the he's kind of hurricane are
you the emperor of kenja what are you
i'm the professional janitor well you're
one of the executives right so i would
say
he comes from the royal family of the
kinjaz right
but he's accepted with dual citizenship
in
jk empire is what is what i'm saying so
he's like the daddy yankee of puerto
rico
teddy the way you said it too
i i would say i would say so he's like
sarah palin in alaska
but he's not fully give me give me more
analogies here i need to understand
because yeah what would it be enrico and
sarah palin alaska isn't really
you're sitting with me the way i want
kim jong-un and then he's
um dennis rodman oh i'm not dennis
rodman you'd be dance right and then
yeah this is just north korea very north
korea here
look more dennis robinson yeah i do but
yeah more kim jong-un
in general conceptually no he's fast
he's a
dictator i think joe's more dennis
rodman yeah
he's a blender he's their baby that's
who joe
oh it could be kim jong-un dennis
robinson i take it he [ __ ] car by
elektra she's
yeah but that's like your mom grandma or
yeah mom kim jong-un
rodman yeah that's your aunt
why you gotta ruin my fantasy yeah
you ruined my he's like kim jong-un
rodney you mean dennis moon
[Laughter]
because it doesn't work like i feel like
i know i feel like i got it you mean kim
dennis
i thought it was kim right it's
his name yeah right yeah rodman oh my
god
oh they say backwards kim is the last
name yeah
[Music]
you